Moving on to our landscape painting tools that we have available, you can see that in
a similar editor window that we had before, you can see that we have the paint, the smooth,
the flatten and the noise. And what's interesting here is we have these layers, which you see
a grass layer, a dirt layer and a rock layer, which has been created through a material
that we have applied to the landscape. So the material creation here is such that we
use a layer blend node. So you can see the layer blend is just this option here. And then what
we'll do is we'll add three expressions here. So you can just hold down three on your keyboard
and left click, and that will bring up this coloured parameter here. Well, it's not a parameter by
default, you can actually right click and make it a parameter if you'd like. So you can call this
grass, you can call this rock, you could call this dirt if you wanted. But the main, the main thing
we want to look at here is this layer blend node, where if we select it, we can actually add elements
to the array by just clicking plus plus plus, that'll be on your bottom left hand of the screen here.
And if you make sure weight blend is assigned here, it should be set to that as default. But for each
index, we then want to give it a layer name, we want to give it grass, maybe dirt, and then rock.
And you can see that this will just go into the base colour of your landscape material. So it
enables you to modify the appearance of part of our landscape by painting textures onto the
landscape to help define some materials. So the tool settings here will work just as they do for
the sculpting mode. And once the key difference is that you need to select the layer you wish to
paint with when you're in landscape mode. So to show you what this looks like, if we've selected
the layer on our landscape mode, you can show that we can either do a weight blended layer,
which is a normal one, or we can do the non weight blended layer, depending on what this
layer is trying to do. So to show you exactly what this looks like, you can see that the weight
blended layer normal is this is the material and you would start painting in the grass.
Whereas if it's non weight blended layer, everything is applied based on on the height of
what your material is on the landscape. So you'll see I've created this super quick material in my
editor here. I'm just going to make sure I go in and apply this material to the landscape,
which you can just use by going back into selection mode, selecting the landscape,
and then the landscape material just needs to be the landscape material there. So we'll just type
in landscape. Try and find it. If I just say m underscore landscape, there we go. And then we'll
apply that landscape material like this. And then if we go back into our landscape tool here,
you can see that we've got our paint tab at the top here. And we essentially just want to be
painting in the layers based on this layer information. So then we just want to press
this little plus icon. And we want to select the weight weighted blend layer in brackets normal.
So just as a reminder, the weight weight blend layers allows you to paint on top of layers,
so the layers can then blend. So we want to use this when we want to blend say rock into
an into dirt, sorry. And if you don't want the the weight, so non weight blended layers,
it allows you to replace layers as you paint over them. So we want to use that when we have
snow covering rocks or dirt, for example. So we can just press this plus button. We want the
normal mode here. It'll suggest some kind of name for you. So you can just click save there.
And then we'll just press plus and then click save. And then we'll just repeat this for the
last time. And then layer normal, save. And then you can save everything here. So save all.
And then when everything's saved, it's just a case of painting in the information that you want. So
if you want the rock, and I'll just make my brush a bit smaller here. But if we wanted the rock,
we're just literally painting in the rock, as you see here. And again, we're changing the settings
such as the fall off, the strength. You know, if you just want the solid rock there, you can do.
Of course, this this won't look as beautiful as it possibly could do if you were actually trying
to do it for for real. But you can imagine we have a dirt layer down here. I'll change the fall off
a bit and maybe we just paint a bit of dirt down there, which is really strong. And then, you know,
we change the tool strength, you kind of get the idea of how you may want the layers to blend.
Your shader will keep rebuilding. You can imagine doing this on a larger scale. But here's a super,
super basic material. Three const variables, vector const variables that we can change the color of.
And you can see that we have the grass, the rock and the dirt. And it means we can paint
that into the landscape and create some beautiful results like you can see here.